e aí já é isso aí
e aí e aí a hora de assistir ao canal
tudo com você e eu estou ótima e estou
aqui agora em brasília brasília onde
mora a presidenta dilma no que se refere
à questão de morar em brasília fazem
show aqui tá fazendo aqui ela é de são
paulo eu estou muito ansioso para ir
para são paulo para saber como é que o
povo de são paulo porque eu vejo que
você já assistiu que vamos ver como é
que as gargalhadas de você então galera
de são paulo capital é dia 18
lá no teatro elis regina no anhembi a
comprar suas entradas no
ingressorapido.com.br mail um link na
descrição do vídeo só clicar e vai já
pro lugar de comprar o ingresso foi no
meu twitter eu pedi pra galera me fazer
perguntas sobre escola que não tem o
costume de abordar a galera fez
perguntas e responder agora o arroba
rafão que o robô lá perguntou você já
caiu na escola como foi se eu já paguei
na escola meus amigos eu tenho um grande
problema que é um problema do blog
iniciado e muita gente tem um banco é
viciado em casa ou seja não carinhoso
las em casa dela já eu não eu tenho um
blog iniciado em celular gente ou juro
pra você e eu não consigo fazer nada sem
o celular na nova tá mexendo mas não sai
uma gota de fezes em que está com o
celular e um dia eu fui para a escola e
o diabo lanche da escola era 11 um
biscoito cream cracker é com um negócio
chocolate 11 espinheiro mezcal com sei
lá
o diabo é um negócio e depois disso
chega um amigo meu com a coca-cola eu
tinha fechado a descer lá com a amiga
minha bater foto é que a mulher tem esse
negócio é ter um celular mesma requer
bater foto nosso porque não sei eu
emprestei o celular para ela e esqueci
que tinha emprestado pra ela não sabe é
legal se ela já tinha perdido e chegou
amigo meu com uma latinha de coca-cola
eu pedi um golo é tomei um gole de coca
cola e neste dia meus amigos eu descobri
que o meu estômago e não aceita
chocolate e refrigerante ao mesmo tempo
não aceito não posso nem tomar coca e
depois comer chocolate nem comer
chocolate depois tomar coca ou vice e
versa isso me dá um revés traz tão
grande no meu estômago que parece que
cada tripulação acionou o tom é aquela
dor de barriga desgraçada no pé
barriga que parece tentado uma agulha na
beira do ko benfica cia ea andorinha
sinhá corri para o banheiro voado eu
achei que eu ia explodir em boston
quando cheguei no banheiro cá eu sentei
eu pensei que todas as mães que eu
explodi aquele valor é um computador ea
dor de barriga e sentei na hora que você
a meu celular meus amigos eu sou uma
pessoa muito religiosa ou eu só estou
muito na região nesse dia eu descobri o
tempo de deus nesse dia descobrir que
deus tem um tempo para tudo eu corria
atrás de cielo acham que te deixar na
minha bolsa voltei pro lado da sala
procurei na minha carteira não achei
lugar nenhum eu comecei a me desesperar
ea tela do batem batem batem batem meu
deus quem viu meu celular pelo amor de
deus eu vou explodir vai sair bosta pela
origem o povo chega amigo meu lá tá 500
foto na página não falhar não me desce
diálogo rico banheiro gente eu descobri
que deus tem um tempo pra tudo naquele
momento é descobrir por que o dia tem 23
horas e 59 minutos e 59 segundos a
porque meu amor que deus tem tempo para
tudo pra cada um de nós
o rapaz só deu tempo eu chegar no vale
deu tempo sentar não só deu tempo eu
chegar no papai noel em direção a esse
vaso em câmera lenta ea moça lucas
branco tocando o destino dela estamos
olhando quer de quem diz eu tentei
juntar os daqui mesmo ela foi naquele
momento eu pensei deus é fiel a roupa a
o princesa sabe não perguntou quantas
canetas perdidas a paz nem contra o gol
de cani pedir eu acho que na escola é só
não se perde mais caneta do que se perde
a virgindade a times de hoje né arroba
luzinha eu pergunto você tinha aquele
professor ou aquela professora chata que
nem um satanás aguenta eu tinha essa
professora chata que nem os atuais
aguenta tanto que ela está viva até hoje
eu tinha um ódio que o professor ele
pode responder não sabe a atenção
professor ninguém pode dizer nada não os
alunos quem descobriu o brasil foi quem
estava colombo fez aqueles que o brasil
foi bem
cabral a atacar e não corrige a
professora a atacando tudo bem não você
que sabe de tudo é que embora tal mas é
obrigatório eu tinha uma tradição que eu
tinha outras duas pessoas que mandam a
gente fazer o trabalho gente chegar com
uma hora de de atrasos as impressoras
eu não vou conseguir terminar agora não
deixa eu posso terminar daqui uma hora e
pregar a senhora não você tem que pegar
agora meu filho você tem que aprender
com seus compromisso você tem que fazer
as coisas com os seus compromissos tudo
é compromisso a vida inteira na vida não
vai ter ninguém espera na hora que você
não você tem que fazer agora entregar
agora a ad a gente fazer cultura
empregava passávamos 12 semanas já fazer
a prova né fazer a prova a professora
quando é que a senhora vai correr a
prova vai entregar nada amanhã depois da
entrega pra vocês passa uma semana duas
semanas mas agora que as prova corrigida
a nota não é porque tem as provas das
outras turmas para a isi é professora do
dono da ponta do sol para corrigir tem
honrado seus compromissos têm que fazer
as coisas com os seus compromissos a
vida não vai ter ninguém esperando você
fosse uma página a prova não vai fazer
calar a boca de quem manda aqui sou eu
olhava a diretoria anuncia cala a boca
que quem manda aqui sou eu viajava
diretoria cala a boca de quem manda aqui
sou eu a diretoria mas que por ele não
gostei não tem palavra ea roupa bruna
maciel perguntou qual era o seu maior
medo na escola meu maior medo na escola
era a escola arroba tapete azul
perguntou já fez sete na escola não me
depois que eu saí da escola demorou 15
anos para fazer sexo é de certa forma já
fez sete na escola assim como juliana
paes com a claudia leitte com angélica
com yudi tamashiro não estou brincando
com angélica na roupa e voltei perguntou
porque sentimos falta da escola quando
estamos de férias e quando estamos de
férias queremos escola e sair com a mãe
qualquer lugar da vida igual pra estar
solteiro que ele está namorando pra mim
tá namorando de que ele está solteiro é
igual quando vocês são paulo queria que
eu fizesse chegar e aí depois eu tô aí
você não quer comprar o ingresso e
assistir no stand up em são paulo dia 18
em arroba hyroshi perfeita então você
era do fundão ou era da frente era do
meio arroba best love ao se pinto qual
foi sua maior nota para confirmar a
baixada é apertada a 10 na madrugada 10
bastava a roupa brinca peixoto perguntou
qual é matéria que você mais gostava a
matéria que eu mais gostava era uma a
matéria do lanche mas é isso aí se você
gostou do vigente para eu continuar
fazendo o vídeo é muito importante que
toda vez todo mundo deixa eu gostei
se você gostou gosto curtiu o vídeo não
esquece deixar o seu gosto e que me
ajuda demais lá no facebook também não
quer deixar aquele lhe quis me ajuda
muito quem impulsiona os 20 mais gente a
assistir e se inscreve no canal pago
perder nenhum vídeo tá lembra você que
eles são paulo dia 18 de julho a gente
tem um encontro no teatro elis regina no
anhembi comprar ingresso como
ingressorapido.com.br o primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo vamos lá é nóis muito
obrigado a assistir se viu até aqui
valeu